i want to make this yeah we're good to
go let's make this podcast [ __ ] the
best ever let's make this
like let's go let's change podcasting
with this podcast that's what that's the
mindset i want because your shoes still
have the tag on it oh my god i didn't
even notice not even notice that's what
the kids were wow i had no idea the
turtle's still on they're awesome i had
no idea oh my god that's so embarrassing
no it's great now let's make this
podcast as dope as those these kicks
yeah god how do you do that thing you
know what you do you tear you tear the
lid off this [ __ ]
you dig you dig into where the gold is
bro okay oh you mean we gotta dig deep
you gotta dig deep and you gotta and
then when you're deep deep you gotta go
even deeper balls deep okay you know how
when you're on your bike your peloton or
you're on your [ __ ] regular bike and
you're doing a hill and you're like my
body i can't go any further then you hit
that you go
sit scared down yeah and now you go
brian i can't go anymore and i know
there's only one thing to do brennan you
go what i go dig even deeper
right
watch this so you and i we're on a
forced march we have no food no water
we're marching hit the walls i hit the
wall and i go like this and it's time to
die and i go i just like oh yeah i know
bro me too and he go what do we do and i
go
let's climb the wall
[ __ ] dude
this podcast we're gonna climb the wall
bro at what at what point when we're
hiking through that forest
because you're older you know and you're
breaking down no i'm not pregnant you
just go
just it's my time you go on and you give
me all your like rations and stuff yeah
and then i'm like i'm gonna have to take
your shoes too dude
i need shoes why because am i going to
wear out eventually well i'll be wearing
my toe holes i don't know if you want
flip-flops here's the handles the doors
not making it do you do you know what
you should do in that situation nobody
thinks about this you're pissed
you're close
you're close take your clothes you're so
close no
what you do is
i'm i'm lying there right i'm at my i'm
i'm down yeah you're right i'm done
now now you are also done i mean we
haven't eaten in three days but i'm
still upright you're still upright
you're strong you got you can still make
it but i'm worried that's a lot of
bodies feed
so what you do and it's [ __ ] ugly
dude i'm like a hibernating bear like i
got fat like i can burn yeah you don't i
know so here's what you're gonna do i'm
gonna pass out like this
i passed out i'm going to eat your
hamstrings no you're going to wake up
you got to get a [ __ ] you get a read
a hollow reed that's sharp
and you just you poke it you make a
small incision in my [ __ ] jugular and
you stick it in my jugular and you drink
all my [ __ ] blood i know it's gross i
know it's gross dude they're mongolian
you have to dude drink my life force
drain me like a [ __ ] vampire leave me
bloodless a husk of bloodless meat and
then you'll make it you'll make it to
your diet there's a question let's say i
make it and they're like
how many of your partner who's with you
don't call him partner because sounds
gay jump up brian yeah he's old died
back then and they go okay how far do
you like about seven miles back you find
them dead yeah they're cool they find
them and they're like oh well he was
still breathing and then apparently you
cut a hole in his neck and then drank
his blood okay now hold on is that
murder no they do this they go like this
they go uh brennan
he had no blood in his body
and then you go like this
and you go you go what and they go he
had no blood in his body someone sucked
them dry and you go so what are you
saying are you saying that i tapped his
vein and sucked all the blood out of his
body is that what you're going to say i
did is that is that literally the theory
you're coming up with you [ __ ] idiot
and then i'd say did you check his nut
sack
those were full on not me
well if you were really if you really
want to survive
you would eat my nuts now let me do some
let me tell you what saggy nuts because
that's testosterone so you'd eat my you
drink my blood and eat my nuts it's
disgusting but you're going to get
yourself ahead little sack jerky have
you watched that show alone on the
history channel or on on netflix no
it's on netflix now but it's been on his
channel for years yeah but netflix just
got it so so [ __ ] um
this is my favorite part about that it's
literally alone they're like in alaska
and they're it's it was 60 days
then they upped it because people are
crushing it you know it was just whoever
lasts the longest yeah some guys still
out there no they're like dude you won a
million he's all cool had like a seven
bedroom condo made out of trees is that
true yeah he's like i'm just gonna stay
oh my god and they didn't know who was
quitting so they would check in on like
one's down two's down but if you're
talking
months i didn't know that yeah they were
like in alaska or something so they
killed a moose yeah so they put this guy
they put
these guys out on this island called
grizzly island out in british columbia
grizzlies everywhere
everywhere it's nice out there though
yeah now as the fish start drying up
they get desperate it's [ __ ]
dangerous so not only do they have like
horns but they have
huge boom sounds that i think there's
somebody
there to scare the bears away you can't
you know
bring up grizzly island bryan it's a
grizzly mountain uh uh is it island or
mountain uh it's i think it's island
dude get rid of a loan chase you just
type in uh there it is
don't don't tell me who wins because i'm
i'm in the middle of it still oh oh i'll
tell you wins white guy white guy all
white guys
white guys white girls now here's the
thing here's what's interesting about it
um
i'm not looking because you're it's not
no this is just the actual island i
don't know there's a grizzy island my
favorite is every time they have a they
have like some people there a lot of
times they're women who are really great
at survival but here's the problem
they're really good at gathering they
gather mushrooms they gather berries
they gather
roots
and they don't bring a bow and arrow
they don't bring a fishing rod and
you gonna starve
you gotta kill animals you gotta kill
[ __ ] animals they're one dude there
was this one dude he had a belly he had
a heart condition i'm like this guy is a
[ __ ] he's so dumb and he he didn't
bring any weapons he tried to kill
grouse they have these like forest hens
you know what his plan was to kill a
grouse to throw a stone at him this
[ __ ] idiot he didn't laugh he threw a
stone and he goes ah damn it now yeah
i'm having chest pins i don't want to
die six days come get me i'm like get
that you're a [ __ ]
some people are yeah alone that's not
the most entertaining show i think like
compared to naked afraid making afraid i
feel like put a little more production
in it it's a little suspect like that
beer grills whatever
like there was that other show the lo
the survivor guy
yeah if you do it real and you don't do
like overproduction like add [ __ ] to it
or like stumble upon a cobra or whatever
if it's like real and you're just
shooting yes
pretty boring yes like alone like
nothing happens no nothing happens like
the chance of getting attacked by
something's not good that's correct ever
that's correct it's very rare dude very
rare very rare very rare by the way try
to catch it try to kill a deer with a
bow and arrow yeah try to do that try to
get close enough
unless that's your thing yeah if you're
just shooting on the weekends the kill
time chance of you killing a live
[ __ ] dare in the real forest daddy
good luck no you got to know animal
behavior you got to know what the tracks
are this guy who did it alone he'd been
doing it his whole life i'm telling you
i don't know what season they're on on
netflix but there's a guy who kills a
moose dude that's a big deal yeah with a
bow and arrow no he jumped on his back
knife throat
blood
i don't know i don't know how he killed
him but i know some guy killed a [ __ ]
moose on there
if you've seen him oh well
good for you he wins yeah also you
realize
nature hates your guts
nature nature don't give a [ __ ] they
don't give a [ __ ]
whatever dude you're gonna you're not
catching anything oh you feel bad for
yourself dude there's a [ __ ]
ram that ran into the [ __ ] barbed
wire fence over there he's been stuck
there yeah and then wolves ate him ass
first yeah and his head's still in the
[ __ ] fence
welcome to nature nature is a
[ __ ] oh and yesterday on [ __ ]
uh happy hour friday that grizzly bear
we watched eat his own [ __ ] cubs you
so hungry
nature also nature is not about
grizzlies also the [ __ ] in nature that's
invisible like amoebas and different
viruses and parasites that [ __ ] you talk
about that one person imagine that one
parasite if you're swimming i guess it's
in fresh water it gets to your brain
just oh you died it's cold it's an abiba
it's an amoeba that gets in your brain
you die it's very random but it's like
you know if it's like still water
whatever you jump in the pool or
whatever and it goes to your brain yeah
you go see the doctor like we're so
sorry yeah like yo but you're so sorry
yeah but we're so sorry i'm so sorry
what'd you say she's like permanently
blinded it went one of them a form of
that it uh ate away at her eye and they
caught it quickly enough i guess it was
like under a contact but it was a
serious serious issue she wants all
sorts of doctors she's she's lucky it
was annoying who was this it's my cousin
yeah you know it was at a pool it was
actually your actual cousin yeah holy
[ __ ] you know someone that got that
weird amoeba and i don't know if it's
the same one but it's one that it eats
away at your eye and she has permanent
damage to her that's why you don't swim
in like in in swamps
in ponds that are not moving there's so
much it's called pam pam is extremely
rare since 1962 only 154 known cases wow
i mean your chances are pretty good but
you can get giardia real quick you can
get these weird things do you you know
what daddy likes to do in nature you
know daddy likes to do i'm hiking if i
see you especially when i was in
colorado if i'm hiking on the road or
whatever i see a stream running daddy
likes put his
mouth down there little nature's here's
the nature's waterfall here's why i
don't know nothing about that there's
what i don't know no if it's running
water right i've seen enough negative
afraid right so if it's running you're
good if it's stagnant water if it's
stagnant daddy's in trouble sometimes
though the running water is coming from
an area that has livestock and when the
livestock is [ __ ] in that or near it
you're going to get yourself all kinds
of [ __ ] in there and you're going to get
listeria you know i just feel good i
always feel i won't do it in foreign
land yeah but in america that fresh
american mountain hitters yeah i just
put my mouth right there
uh-huh never got sick my boy nothing
better my boy um
i think it was both uh bradley cooper
and uh will arnett back in the day i got
them into raw food and juice and there
was this raw food market got closed down
um by the fda but um i had them i had
them getting green juice and eating raw
meat
and bradley got a [ __ ]
amoeba you get sick from it he goes dude
i caught an amiibo i'm not going back
there he was so sick it was an amiibo
will [ __ ] you up it'll just oh
one tiny little invisible organism well
[ __ ]
tiny dude tiny yeah that pam thing dude
ins it goes to your brain okay
done see ya we're sorry and they can't
really they can't get it out of your
brain oh no
i don't know if i'm the doctor right and
i come in i'm like
we did our uh we did our uh testing
stuff like that you have the pam amoeba
and you hammer and you go
what i go i'm so sorry like what do you
mean
you're done it's just gonna put this
light you're done
so they can't get it out
apparently not then once you get it
you're kind of [ __ ]
that's impressive it's a death sentence
come on man
give me some give me something in there
now imagine if some foreign evil person
that runs another country want to spread
that around
i those things are hard to well you
could you could do probably you know
what you do
you make them uh it's pam curable look
at that you put them in i said nice 97
fatality rate well that's not good
i tell you why you want to kill
americans tell you what you do you make
one of those pam things [ __ ]
heat
resistable put in fries french fries
that's a good idea that one's for free
genetically engineer
something so they're like germ yeah but
it lives like heats fine like you can
deep fry waffle fries or chick-fil-a
yeah
we're all [ __ ]
you put in a funnel cake at disneyland
well they they keep saying kobit was
probably unofficially created yeah well
yeah the scientists in that lab are the
first ones to get it so what were you
saying about a wet market
yeah oh no evidence that we don't we
don't want to get this episode flag yeah
fellas is that what will happen oh yeah
yeah man we get flagged for the littlest
things they're on us
wow so sensitive they're wrong guys can
we i mean it's just a different can we
live in
anyway it's not like we haven't been
back we've been pegged i don't know
controversial
i told you about the conversation this
girl had she was mad at her man
and she goes he likes to be pegged
and we were all like oh she's like i
can't hear that about my friend
i can't do that right now that's a huge
problem for me you can't give that
information up young lady that's when
she puts a strap again a flag but she is
when she puts a strap on and then does
you in the booty yes interesting yeah
but please don't tell me that about
somebody i know that's not i know you
guys are like a manly man
yeah i know you guys are about to bring
i know i don't want to say that i'm not
saying who it is but i'm just saying i
don't want to i don't want to hear that
about
about your man i don't want to that's
not information that i should know it'd
be heartbreaking if you walk down you're
dead getting pegged by your mom there
are i guess some people that are into it
oh damn dad i am daddy i know a pretty
famous actor who's into that not anybody
actors make sense not anybody we know
you know they get so bored with just
regular sex they're like dude we gotta
mix this up
yeah i don't know him i just know of him
i trust the girl who was with him oh
yeah i trust her
yeah what'd you do this weekend b you
were for some reason i thought you're on
tour no
daddy
daddy was editing his special
pretty happy with that i was editing the
sammy the bull gravano best dubs which
are going to look [ __ ] sick
best of uh what'd you do with brian on
youtube
and then i uh i went to the beach i did
some spike ball
i did some volleyball
and nothing makes me more sore and beats
my body well that's why you feel like
that probably yeah that's why you're all
sore i think so yeah you're moving
around like yeah and [ __ ] and then i
play with my baby who likes to smile and
laugh
and i kissed the [ __ ] a little spike
ball huh who'd you play with it's so fun
dude four random white guys yeah you
just found them no no they're my buddies
i meet around there what's great about
the beach is you spend all day at the
beach then you go eat and it's just i
don't know i love the beach i love that
i love being around the ocean [ __ ]
so do i
and the water right now is so beautiful
the water is
it never changes it's warm it's not
though oh it's so warm no pacific no no
it's listening i was just watching it
yesterday it's stupid warm and i it's
almost always cold it's
[ __ ] down i was watching the news maybe
it's in south bay but in general
no general the atlantic ocean they're
one of the questions pacific at the
pacific ocean and ktla they they're like
why is it always cold even the sum of
the [ __ ] oceans
the currents if showing all the currents
it will never get now the south bay
because the bay yeah will be warmer
mm-hmm it's warm that's where people
surf and stuff
but it was warm yesterday boy
i don't like like florida water like
bahama water like it's like so warm and
you're in the sun so it's not like an
escape yes that's why i i prefer the
pacific all day all day yeah you're the
kind of guy i love it when it's cold so
it's in that hot seat you swim in that
water when it was super cold deep deep
i'm there with the great whities you're
just diving around like you seem like a
seal with your arms pinned to your
[ __ ] hips like a seal oh dude i know
i meant to tell you we've had a coyote
problem in woodland hills on the ring
app there's just all these coyote
signings all right quit reporting it for
god's sake they live here
but there's now there's been one in our
backyard not small no now i go in the
hot tub with my son every night when we
go back there here
i'm like t get back i look that [ __ ]
county in the back there with the hot
tub
big but always runs off getting a little
too comfortable if they keep coming
around we talk to the to somebody like
if it's food or something like the
promise he's too comfortable it's not
good if they keep the most adaptable
animal in the world they can eat fruit
yeah off trees i'd say a roach but i'm
with you but then um
the other problem is is then three
blocks down
the old line of the mountain said
hold my bear ah leon de la montagna dude
leon
and you have one of those there's one
roaming around wow really yep and little
boston you know like you've seen on we
we brought up current events those
coyotes
grabbed a kid at the beach yeah that's
right so dude high alert that's my other
thing i told you i'm like that [ __ ]
mountain light starts roaming here we
gotta shoot it you know it's illegal
if a mountain lion's in my [ __ ]
backyard and i got little children lock
up your dogs i'm shooting that thing
right in the face right right in his
[ __ ] i'm sure you're not gonna go to
prison you're just gonna pay a hefty fee
uh we're gonna we're gonna taxidermy
that thing first of all no you're not
because if the lion mountain lion's in
my [ __ ] backyard and i got a child
i'm gonna shoot him in his [ __ ] face
even though i love mountain lions
there are a lot of them out there
yeah
oh one guy got 30 days i'll do 30 days
no you you would not get prosecuted if
the lion was in your backyard and your
children were there and you shot it
that's that's protecting your children
that's not
well the problem is you have the all the
cameras around so you have to prove that
there was a danger i i i'd be a danger
just be in the vicinity of it if it's in
your backyard and you shoot it you're
you're not going to jail i don't care
what anybody says
i mean i if i have a lot go back to he's
coming back
in trouble
that got in trouble yes
you can't have a dog california man
philly shoots mountain lion gets 30 days
30 day 240 hours of community service
that's hefty daddy doesn't have that
time
there's ways around that i'm sure
yeah but he probably killed it yeah just
to kill it right i would never do that
he's just being a dick
but if you're in my pocket you're going
down too children are
nuisance
hmm it was destroyed
yeah i wonder how many unicorns online
so it sounds like he killed in like a
[ __ ] in the in in nature yeah he
listed in your backyard like circling
your pool yeah i gotta take you out dude
that's not cool
scary right i look every morning every
night
i like how they caught him
but the other one he shot him and killed
him and it was legal because it was if
it's a threat to your
i said livestock or yes animals your
animals or
pets and killed in california if it's in
your backyard you you i would never take
a chance because if a mountain lion's in
my backyard
that i don't know when that mountain
lion is coming back to my backyard and
my children play back there and then
there it is they won't hear it no that's
honestly you will not hear your
to be clear he hasn't been in my
backyard he's in the two two doors down
though so in colorado and a family was
hiking and with their six-year-old and
and they were all hiking in a line okay
and the six-year-old's in the middle of
the parents a mountain lion came out of
nowhere grabbed that child and ran off
and you never see it happen it just
happened so quickly it's so silent
the coyote is a little more you know
they're everywhere dude yeah coyotes i'm
not as worried about a mountain lion
will grab your kids and run and you're
gone you'll never see it is a problem
man
less so
the person we were talking to the nature
person was saying the problem is if he
keeps coming back the same because if it
just went through once all good if he
keeps coming back you got a problem
maybe let's take a little break for the
best podcast ever this was the best
podcast so far of all time dude it's
shocking you know what else is the best
what's happening i heard fort wayne
indiana this thursday friday saturday
because i'm going to be there i heard
you're going to be there i'm going to be
there the trash can the summer tour a
whole new hour is coming for wayne
indiana with the thick boy crew
we have good recommendations for
restaurants sure you only had three air
and bees with three airbnb so we found
one of the three guys not a lot of
airbnb's there but daddy's coming to
town this thursday friday saturday um
and then shop and friends next hollywood
improv is next wednesday late show 10
p.m shop and friends was a very special
guest that's one show only then san
diego
sea lions are the only thing coming to
your city
it is your boy at the lab factory in
downtown san diego july 21st the 23rd
they got baltimore chicago appleton
houston boston but fort wayne you're up
and then you're then i'm in san diego
next week get your tickets at
thickboy.com b where are you going to be
well let's take a little break and talk
about a couple things first of all if
you like to watch good content messed up
with brian callen on youtube you might
want to check that out okay uh i got
sammy the bull gravano episodes never
heard of them [ __ ] pumped about them
we did some crazy [ __ ] together is that
i got this we'd be yep
the first episode then the second one
drops uh it'll be out this wednesday
possibly thursday it depends we're
trying to figure out exactly when to
drop it you're trying to crank it out
huh yes brookfield wisconsin milwaukee
improv july 21 22-23 now is that just
milwaukee that's just milwaukee buddy
but it's in brookfield yeah it feels
like a suburb it's like it's like a part
of it austin texas cap cities i haven't
been back there in four years man july
28 29 30. i love cap city different cap
cities and new cap city new owner
supposed to be sick yep mark grossman my
buddy yeah amazing nashville tennessee
zany's august 25 26 27 actually august
26 27 i'm gonna change that
um specan washington spokane comedy club
september 22 23-24 that's where i'm at
dude listen you want to talk about a
great podcast you want to talk about
doing a great thing look at the end of
the day sometimes you might be a little
sore
you might be a little bit stressed you
might need to calm down the all-natural
way is all i'm saying bro okay we're
talking about cbd listen dude if you've
ever wondered whether cbd was actually
working that means it probably wasn't
because if using real cbd and your boy
here knows a thing or two about cbd yes
you do this company i've been waiting
for do an ad read firm this is real so
it's next evo naturals they have a sleep
aid cbd it's their cbd sleep product yup
and i was like yeah you know sometimes i
have trouble sleeping like i'll try it
i've used it every night since two pills
clinically and your boy is
sleeping like a grizzly bear in
hibernation it knocks your boy out this
smart sword technology is clinically
proven clinically proven to help your
body absorb cd four times better than
regular cbd oil okay so it it see
because oil doesn't just mix with your
water-based body okay it works faster
too when you feel stress coming on you
won't waste time wondering is it working
because it does okay and i'm telling you
man for i've done all the sleep stuff
you name it the yep the pharmaceuticals
your body
nothing knocks me out like they're
sleeping pills really their cbd slim
build knock yo i bring it on the road
with me now everywhere i gotta get this
after i do stand up it's hard to sleep
after stand up right now you get all
amped you're amped two of these and if i
want to get and it works in like little
as 10 minutes right dude i'm telling you
i my girl like what are you using
because i we don't get through shows
anymore it knocks me out dude really i
can't wait to read because i this is
one of the few products i actually use
every single it's called next evo not
tony it's right freaking legit well
they're scientifically formulated to
deliver more cbd in a way your body can
actually use and they're the only cbd
company i know that are backed by
science yeah all right yep they're
delicious it's fantastic it freaking
works i'm telling you dude i love cbd
and it's their cbd sleep is what i use
so stop wondering if cbd is right for
you try it out they've got dummies
capsules mints i use creams
try next evo naturals capsules gummies
mints topical creams clinically proven
to be better absorbed by your body get
25 off your first order of 40 or more at
nextevo.com with the promo code fighter
that's 25 off at
n-e-x-t-e-v-o dot com promo code fighter
next evo.com prom code fighter
oh thank god dude business wars is here
it's a podcast from laundry that shares
entertaining eye-popping stories behind
the world's greatest business rivalries
the newest season of one of these
business wars a four-part series hosted
by david brown explores them it's about
gucci vitamins oh the bitter feud
between the two fashion icons gucci and
money status power struggles
dude listen they both start off smallest
and you fashion heads out there we know
this story they both start off small
family-owned businesses making
high-quality luggage at first glance
they have a lot of flowers
but as the product lines grew
it set these two powerhouses on a
collision course before long the rivalry
would devolve into family feuds
boardroom battles and runway backstabs
listen to gucci vs louis vuitton from
business wars on apple podcasts amazon
music or listen one week early on ad
free by joining one replus in apple
podcast or laundry app
business wars
if he keeps coming back you got a
problem my ex-wife was in a serious
relationship with a guy and it was like
you know they're getting to an age where
it's like maybe we'll get married and
she's told me that she was with her
parents and with this guy and they were
hiking as like just you know
and
they're hiking and
he's ahead and she just sees she just
sees him running top speed towards them
and he and he
keeps running and as he passes them he
goes there's a mountain lion there's a
mountain lion and he just runs away from
the mountain
and she was like well that's not a man
i'm going to [ __ ] do it this guy
didn't even that's not set to protect us
this [ __ ] loser ran save yourself
literally did that it just kept running
past and she was like oh you're not the
guy for me that was it for her she was
like hey you and i broken up he did hurt
the hell
though [ __ ] yeah he did
yeah well hopefully those mountain lions
don't come into the backyard
hopefully i haven't seen i've seen other
reports
yeah that's two days ago
and also not that big those grizzlies on
alone are scary as [ __ ] guys in the
water he's just washing he's ah all of a
sudden he goes
he looks up and he goes the camera's
like that's a grizzly and it's right
there and he goes and i'm naked in the
water and the grizzly starts coming
towards him and they they
i think the camera whoever is there for
grizzly bear
they set off a boom
and a thing ran to scare them away at
first it wasn't going away you know they
said that bill grills uh yeah was it no
bear grylls
they said he'd like all right guys i'm
gonna turn the cameras off now we're
gonna stay the night here he's like
shivering like cut and then a [ __ ]
chopper
yes picks him up takes him to four
seasons yes the next one wakes up super
early
drops him back down yeah i'm not mad at
it he did his time it's entertainment
yeah well most of those discovery
channels most of the they they when they
see a snake in the wild or they see it's
all set up it's all set up yeah
all of it see i was our bo our boy was
it coyote peterson yeah the the was it
wild and afraid or whatever brave
wilderness yeah some of that like when
he's like i've i found a bullet ant
right here mo
he might have i mean yeah he's like
what'd you say
he i yeah either he's doing it for kids
so either way oh i i don't give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm just saying
like is he finding all like there's
poetic license taken right
yeah i mean he still gets he still gets
stung by the goddamn thing yeah that's
real yes
yes looks like it [ __ ] hurts too man
oh yeah do you guys like survivor man
sure so it's just him filming himself
but i find it entertaining see i don't
find entertainment for a purist you're
going to like that because you know
he'll hike so he hikes sets up the
cameras to film him going down yeah and
then what you don't see is then he has
to go back grab the cameras and carry on
so
it takes forever yeah
so
bear grylls is just doing the goddamn
thing yeah
you need a camera crew
yeah
it's just tough man if you can do it
that way you know i don't when i would
shoot me eater you always had a camera
guy with you always
but surviving men will talk about bear
girls teaching survival
but bear grylls does all the stuff you
shouldn't do like jumping over things
because people that's how they die like
they snap an ankle and they die well
bear gryffindor
was an sas guy he was uh like the
equivalent of delta yeah i know he could
do he's a bad [ __ ] oh but uh
survivorman's saying you you shouldn't
show people yeah that's how you survive
that's not how you should survive oh
yeah yeah
i don't know i'll be i don't want to ask
you it makes sense if they are do your
kids wear crocs
they do my son does yeah
it's all the craze right now right they
all yeah heartbreaking yeah
comfortable as [ __ ] that's the
these are comfortable yeah the shoes are
comfortable they're just easy
some yeezys are so cool my question to
you is this
like there is something about wearing
there's a discipline to dressing well
right there's a discipline to wearing
good like even shoes that aren't as
comfortable right you can walk around
pajamas your whole life but there's a
reason we wear clothes that just take a
little time right these are two size 12
i wear 13. yeah i wear 12 because
fashion is painted it
changes your there's a discipline you
don't think i wish these were 13 or 14.
there's 12 because the only size they
there's a discipline to looking well to
looking good i don't know when became
acceptable just like [ __ ] it
like wearing sandals like on a plane
like open
i'm eating dude yes you usually have
your toenails yes well that might be and
i never do that that might be that might
be a reflection of a larger sort of
breakdown oh why because we're all
beast yeah
by all i mean you know in general oh but
i mean but i mean
the the there is a disciplined breakdown
there's a casualness
that that i think um
so those are these invisible kind of
like prices you pay for things like you
can be super casual but my guess is it
leaks over into society right you're in
your own life oh a hundred percent in
your own life yeah i'm saying then it if
someone goes oh well that guy's
successful and he wears pajamas and
crocs to work i'm gonna do it and then
it slowly becomes acceptable and the
next thing you know you're on a plane
and guy has his big toe in your food
well al magical used to always say when
he was hiring people he would go walk
them out to their car if their car was
messy they didn't get the job
interesting and it's very true and there
are a lot of things like that where you
can look at somebody let nobody wants to
admit this you can look at somebody a
lot of times and there are a lot of
signals that you can see right there
you are the enemy of yourself yes and
you're going to be a problem
so yeah my kids are into it the problem
you know i did a whole video on it i was
with tiger you know it's either he's
sick so you know him through his son
same thing they play he's out he's on
black not playing basketball he's in the
sand so whatever should get him gets
absolutely
if it lasts a month it's like damn
that's a good shoe destroys him yeah
he's destroyed oh boy oh boy destroys
them i'm like were you playing an actual
hot lava why how do you do you chewing
on these
and so
he knew shoes and weeks prior about
crocs i'm like absolutely not not
happening dude not in this household
you're not bringing crocs in there and
he dropped it i'm like that's cool but
all his buddies weren't so then i took
him to the mall on uh saturday and he's
like dad dropping the bears crocs and
saying they all wear crocs i'm like [ __ ]
sakes dude [ __ ] someone just get crocks
i look at them like you think those look
good dude that's you said yeah he's like
yeah i'm like all right
it hurts your eyes oh dude you're one of
those guys but it hurts
disgusting
yeah they're all tie-dye and then they
you can put [ __ ]
stickers on them and god damn it dude
that's an interesting curse it's like my
buddy who is a painter he goes i gotta
get out of la i go why i guess because
i'm always fixing things everything is
so ugly nobody takes the time to make
something beautiful
i was like i get it thank god there are
people like you or we wouldn't have i
get as kids you know for them it's just
so yeah it's the cool things they want
what their friends have
sure i always told tea and it's true yes
jay and i got a lot of heat for it when
i was in elementary school whatever
everyone was doing i was the exact
opposite you love fashion exactly but i
love it i took like jared leto risk in
fourth grade like first day of fourth
grade i wore a with a bolo tie and a
silk shirt shorts and cowboy boots
everyone's like oh are you trying to get
bullied
i was like i sure am but meet my big
brother jay that's amazing yeah jay was
like please don't dress like them like
it's going down
that's so interesting that was very
weird so i told tm like whatever if your
friend's doing this i'd go this way i
said even if crocs is the thing what are
the color of theirs he's like black like
then don't get black get a different one
i love it that's just something that's
in you yeah
but there are people like that and i
think that that i used to when i was
younger i used to make fun of that now
what i realized is that is a huge part
of what makes a culture interesting for
sure artistic expression fashion we love
to make fun of fashion as an example
are you wearing anything different
that's not the norm people like oh nice
hat yeah it's your culture interesting
and so did the people that do it so i
watched those fashion shows i told you
right and i used to make fun of those
people they're creative as [ __ ] there's
some interesting stuff the problem with
those fast shows is they're not the
problem i have with those fast shows
nobody can wear that stuff they don't
make any sense that's the point no it's
all it's an art show it's like a formula
one car right correct nobody can drive
it but the technology that yeah yeah
good point and and so the couture
couture is like it's very important and
i never understood the value of that but
art itself it's just art it's an it's an
expression it's an original
self-expression it happens to be in
fabric
i was watching on something i work at
this hat i'm like we can you can even
drive a car right like that's not
practical right she's going to hold it
in the back of the uber and then get out
like
yeah
it takes away right yeah you got to hold
your body in a certain way
you know but there's a discipline to it
yeah
this kid got their goddamn crocs
it's easy they want to slip in and out
i'm like god damn it dude well that's
why like in in
back in the day in england you you came
to dinner if you were in the upper crust
in a suit and tie bro
in shoes if you look back in the day all
of them have the top hats three-piece
suits and think they'd have ac back then
they also built some [ __ ] and they still
dress like that in the summers they
built some [ __ ] too
a lot of the stuff that we enjoy now is
built on the foundation of that this
probably smelled like [ __ ]
tornado fitness steam room think about
it they're just [ __ ]
they're like in the summers in a
three-piece wool three-point suit in
europe back in the day in the 1700s
1800s you would see people they'd be
holding a handkerchief with perfume to
their nose because the streets smelled
so badly nobody brushed their teeth oh
yeah nobody bathed and also you had
running sewage in the streets it's good
stuff
that's tough yeah there's an
infrastructure that we benefit from you
know the pipes underground that take all
the [ __ ] that we make yeah let's talk
and process it
right mark yeah right mark
i agree i just did i thought mark was
you know what'd you do this weekend chin
um went hiking in orange county by
yourself not me my buddy see any
wildlife
yeah we did what birds birds yeah
and the trails i go on because you know
during the panda we got to see so much
wildlife because there weren't a bunch
of humans scaring things off i saw the
coolest wildlife now nothing very rare i
even see a snake why unless you go super
early because
all the wildlife when people because so
packed now oh yeah wildlife just like
we're good right but when there's covet
and they shut those things down but your
boy is still doing it gotta take it
there was everything bobcats got [ __ ]
rattlesnakes up the gazoo that's right
it was so fun now you [ __ ] i remember
that you see like i would film it for
you every time i know put on my [ __ ]
story every day giant ones they got so
bad people like do quit posting rattle
snakes that's how many snakes i would
post now you're lucky if i find one
because there's so much traffic yeah so
the snake's like we're out
they feel that vibration it's just all
the traffic they didn't want to deal
with it
yeah i'm not posting campaigns like you
should grab that thing i'm like are you
out of your mind i can no i'm not
pregnant you wouldn't just by the tail
i mean you've seen it the fact that cam
hayne shot a grizzly bear with a bow and
arrow is the sickest thing have you ever
seen how big that grizzly was that he
killed without an arrow he shot it while
it was lying there but he had to make a
good shot if you don't do that you
you just piss in the bear yeah and it's
still coming at you he's coming at you
well you know that guy remember that guy
who got all that [ __ ] for killing that
line he flew over to africa yeah
murdered yeah murdered that dennis got
murdered last week yeah he got what yeah
what yeah three lions in the target
parking lot
i'm just kidding no he did get murdered
though no he got the joke was the lines
in the parking lot he actually there's
no joking him getting murdered yeah that
actually happened yeah that's terrible
yeah
yeah what that that's terrible
because he was not um he thought it was
a legal kill
dentist who killed the cecil the lion
trophy hunter killed lions and elephants
shot dead in south africa
mm-hmm whoa hold on
after his truck don't say he slaughtered
lions and elephants he shot him
and paid for it um
and that money goes to preserving the
habitat you [ __ ] idiot on monday
after his truck hold on let me go back
krueger national 50 hour was gunned down
at close range when a car pulled up next
to his truck what
could it have just been a coincidence or
it could have been something like you
quit killing those lions and tigers
they actually he could have been he
could well it didn't sound like he got
robbed so that's yeah i know
now why did he was sort of picked out i
mean he can't be the only person killing
lions and zimbabwe right but for some
reason
he was that uh
dentist from north dakota so this is a
different person though but he also died
right no no this is a different guy okay
that's no the guy who killed cecil yeah
he's not killed he was not killed oh
this is okay it's a different thing just
making sure okay
hey man wait are we sure cecil didn't
die yeah no you see something no cecil's
the one who died and you said that guy
got killed go back chin no
did they both die
no
walter paul [ __ ] had me going there
well hold on well i'm looking at one
that says dentist who killed cease of
the lion slammed for slaughtering oh no
this is a different one
yeah this guy was in the news recently
oh he's in the news for slaughtering a
rare sheep in mongolia
oh he's just like he killed for it and
it goes all it's a sheep right yeah but
the sheep that money goes to preserving
the habitat hey is he killing those [ __ ]
for your sandals he's not the enemy yes
that way you're defending him we use
sheepskin now listen some of them yes
it's for the conservation animals some
of them just want to kill animals right
well that's for sure i know somebody
who's like i just like to kill things i
was like 100 percent interesting yeah
i'm not interested in that i don't like
killing the animal i love you can always
say
you're never getting me to kill a
[ __ ] lion i don't want to do any of
that if if
if i spend 300 grand to kill a lion an
elephant and it goes back to the
preservation of the elephant habitat
i'll shoot it right now but that's an
old healthier
yeah i don't know well whatever they do
when you get it
when you get a tag you get yeah the ball
that's killing the other it's not
breathing anymore it it's older it's
there's all there's all these
stipulations i don't know if i believe
that sometimes you know in fact well i
know but they're yeah so they just like
got one's really mean and he can't have
babies
no so so one of the biggest things
when you have
elephants in south africa they kill them
all the time and botswana the way you
manage the population is you ha and
here's the other threat in the herd you
can't just kill like if you take an
elephant herd and you kill like the
mature female it's a disaster because
they go crazy they they are a family and
there's a whole structure there so when
you kill
sometimes they kill the whole goddamn
herd people don't realize this because
you when you kill just one or you two or
you relocate one or two they go crazy
you can't do that tonight the whole
family
there's a lot of other [ __ ] that goes on
when you want to manage elephants if you
also do we have to manage them yes you
do we can't nature manage them because
we don't have the habitat and what
happens is they strip everything and
then they'll starve anyway or they do so
much damage
nope they go into the farmer's territory
then they get shot anyway there's a
thousand problems managing elephants in
kruger national park or any of these
national parks tanzania botswana is a
major major event they try to sterilize
them
try doing that [ __ ] sometime enjoy that
see how much that costs when you have to
dart an elephant from a helicopter land
it sterilize it it's a it's such a
nightmare so the truth is yeah the truth
is it's it's an ugly business but if you
don't do it you know i think it's shark
week too speaking of animals yeah bored
i'm bored
i don't get how they do it
it's it's the same foot there's no new
footage
there's no new shark they all kill the
exact same way the marketing on shark
week is impeccable yeah how the [ __ ] did
you're just
out of the water yeah every time yeah
it's been the same since i was a kid
yeah
there's nothing new no new shark you got
to create danger no the new thing they
do like oh here's shaquille o'neal with
a great white all right yeah
there's nothing there's nothing great
what's wrong we've covered lights are
now mainstream yeah we're swimming with
great whites as maine we've covered it
all dude
like if you've if you posted a video if
you swim with a great white on instagram
you're like yeah well you know you know
tim kennedy's swimming in morro bay
a lot of people wouldn't do that yeah
because the great whites hunt in that
area for sure and that's probably not a
good idea to be swimming at dawn or
before dawn out in the middle of nowhere
you are in the only thing out there i'm
just curious on discovery channels
marketing when they meet before i'm sure
they meet months prior it's like all
right what's the what's the hook
yeah
yeah
what about tiger shark did that dude
four years ago right right right uh what
about the bull shark also did the bull
yeah uh great white overplayed dude yeah
what else we got think about that beast
dude it's a beast they've covered
everything
we know nothing new about them there's
nothing new
it's all the same every year it's
disgusting
to be the host of that and josh got it
and i remember that it was the same
thing though trying to drum up
excitement about
great whites and okay
there's a guy who just posted his
instagram um
i'm gonna send this to chin drone
footage of people
like in the water and they don't know
sharks yeah they're all juveniles
yeah that's insulting the sharks
well
some of them are we don't know stingrays
we don't know that no they're sharks but
we've seen that before
again
mark my point is there's nothing you can
show me with a shark that we haven't
seen yet well i saw i saw the video that
was not blurred of that great white that
killed that swimmer in australia and
it's scary you just see blood everywhere
man that thing was [ __ ] so there's a
bunch of these kind of videos i don't
know if he tells like if you can
communicate with that person but
it's just pretty crazy
1500 likes
that's it
that's a big unless you're getting
attacked dude people aren't way bigger
than his board by the way oh my god
thing is massive also that shark don't
give a [ __ ]
no he's like you're swimming i mean it's
cool i would be lit if that was me
scares me
four great whites two surfers
oh wow yeah now those are juveniles to
your point
still pretty big also that water super
clear these guys don't give a [ __ ] now
how do you know they're juveniles just
because they're size mark size mark
seismic they're using a great white
truck sling also they're eating
stingrays and those kinds of things the
big oceanic sharks never get them unless
there's a whale on the shore
and that scent brings them in those are
dolphins
but if
in santa barbara there was a whale on
shore and this
25-footer was just like swimming around
because it was picking up the scent
look at that that's a big shark though
now would you be scared in the water if
a shark was that far away oh yeah
i thought you're gonna say no i can't be
[ __ ] my hands i have nightmares
because
because of the media
right because in general you're fine
dude yeah in general 99 percent of the
time you're fine
but media
have you how many times you've been
watching a show they're just going to
show the shark are friendly swimming by
no one won't see that [ __ ]
jaws started the [ __ ] hysteria with
great whites and then discovery channel
went hold our bear for every year our
biggest week is going to be just shark
attacks yeah
and so you're just terrified friendly
you're terrified misunderstood
you've seen when people take their great
whites and uh uh photoshop
them smiling with cool teeth they look
so friendly
they look like the friendliest animal on
the [ __ ] planet
they have your teeth you look like the
great whites when they put the teeth in
them that's brian with his invisalign
that second one in there's brian
hilarious there's your teeth look at
that thing though how cool do they look
look at that look at that one look at
that
don't they look kind of friendly
you wouldn't be scared at all
but look at that look at that killing
machine
i mean yes and no the chances are you're
good man yep
but i would be [ __ ] my pants mark if
i was
swimming in the water and someone's like
bro there is a large
[ __ ]
huge male great white about two feet
from you well the guy who got hit if you
look at that there's a video of it the
guy would hit in australia apparently
don't say hit though don't say hip-hop
yeah that that was like attacked
17-footer and apparently bring it up
australia someone got attacked a swimmer
man yeah were you seeing great white
attack in australia is that the lady no
this was the guy who swam he's a long
distance you don't watch world star dude
lady cruise ship oh i saw that heck
karen swear
that's in chile yeah
that's in the middle of the ocean that's
not a good time that was a massive shark
but this
if the one in australia he was a swimmer
and uh
uh dude swimmer it's crazy yeah he's a
swimmer he's a long distance swimmer it
happened very recently
and uh
bad news bad news i think i'm i'm scared
of a tiger shark too man no not that mrs
swimmer
okay this shark just went by him and he
says guys terrified now this thing
shredded him and they think it was a
territorial bite they think he wasn't
trying to eat him it's just ripped him
they always say that they always say
that uh he you just give him a a taste
that might be the guy this is a february
yeah that's it i think
wow look at that it's so rare though
wait go back to that what does that say
wait go up up up
a swimmer died in the first fatal shark
attack at a sydney beach in nearly six
decades that can't be true i'll take
those odds but that can't be true well i
think they bite and let you go but then
you lose your leg or you get all [ __ ]
up dying wow
then the next article says shark bikes
surged in 2021.
and then
then the other article said more shark
attacks have occurred since last year
than any other time yeah this guy got
[ __ ] up though um he got shredded they
had to pick up pieces of his body like
this shark just said i'm going to shred
you it could have been a female
apparently they don't know but it was
like a
oh and i feel safe two australian states
say their sharks will no longer attack
they will only bite
oh cool
you get into a shark spring
i love it when they go no there's video
of it i love it when they go they don't
like the taste of humans
really guy's going oh no
oh no it's a giant great white he's
attacked him it's terrible oh no hey b
you think it's fake buddy no no did you
see him take care no no
100 real daddy watching take care of
videos again 100 real you get tricked
sometimes my buddy jimmy burkos i had to
go to meetings because i got
i i was doing i got [ __ ]
addicted to tick-tock jimmy burke he was
like i just kept holy yeah that's what
it's designed for it's weird is it
hijacks your brain that's why daddy
don't have on the phone i don't believe
you eat your life away yep
i don't know why you're having trouble
with this it was big news i mean jen is
typed in are we sure it's australia
maybe just type in recent shark attack
and take off instagram for me did you
see on instagram b
that's right uh yeah you'll see it
this one here six foot long shark
savages swimmer and waist high no it's a
giant giant shark
shark attack swimmer 68 killed by shark
in egypt
not this one 50 seconds swimmer attacked
by shark near lovers point in pacific
grove no law it was in australia he said
[ __ ] what month
uh i don't know like six months chilling
footage shows great white shark moments
after fatal attack i got it that's two
weeks ago
a huge great white shark attacks the
swimmer eat swimmer at the sydney beach
and that's right that the one we're
looking for
[Music]
you can see it though they were the guy
was fishing and what did you see it on b
it was just it was all over yeah the
news and on on um
i mean the
news had blocked it was news for a while
they like blurred it out so you can see
it yeah
probably this one
i'll see the video huh do you have the
video there
it's so [ __ ] up
the birds are swimming around it's
really nuts
i think they're taking it down not only
did that shark they might kill that guy
but she also killed this podcast
coming to screeching halt looking for
this video this is what just dead
silence
it's just a little break it's little
shark breaks oh oh damn it i thought i
found it on youtube
i just saw the actual footage without
the blurring and it was like and where
did you see it brian i'm not going to
ask again
i saw it on the live youtube this might
be it is that's it oh i think we watched
this already that's it
oh yeah it's just splashing around right
yeah
but that's it you see the [ __ ] like
you can just see the [ __ ]
water thrashing it's crazy dude
i don't see him someone just got eaten
by sharks yeah i've watched this before
big great one look at that look at that
look at that [ __ ] you can see the man oh
no who knew i know
you know what the thing is it is too
late to jump in and help no you cannot
jump in also i wouldn't be swimming in
that water
is he though
that looks terrible he's getting it is
that him swimming
that's the shark god the cameraman is
the worst of all time he's probably in
shock yeah but hold the camera still i
know yeah is he swimming or just
it looked like he was trying to get away
i guess just fishing with a mask dude
the thing is still got him
out bro
they just grab you and [ __ ] start
shaking man yeah
video is terrible yeah
yes you see his fins that's a big shark
i mean kind of that ain't no juvenile
you know what i'm saying bro no i don't
know very mature yeah
that ain't no that ain't no they know
they're no youngster
that thing is taking a boy just dying in
the water like that
not how i want to go they couldn't it
could mean through you dude your arms
are too big that's true
what a car any time like a car almost
hits me like i'm walking across the
street i'm like i'd like to see him try
damn yeah that's like dude no go ahead
[ __ ] up your b did i tell you you know
uh tall george and big george they
signed up uh for this um what's it
called chin i think we're still warriors
no no no no no uh-oh oh
it's old name
uh [ __ ] i forget the name of it it's a
20-week program they train monday
through friday also warriors ulta
warriors they train monday through
friday yeah they're with alberto crane
at legacy mma
and they have just world-class trainers
come in they train monday through friday
hour a day and they learn uh like you
know the just the basics of fighting at
the end of it they can choose to do a
smoker and not against someone going
through the same program wow isn't that
cool really cool alberto crane's your
[ __ ] jiu jitsu
what if they wanted to do a smoker
against just somebody who they work with
like fight each other who's like in like
who you know does like a podcast
oh brian we can't have him get head
drama oh really i'm not absolutely
waiting i'm just not going to get would
you give him
yeah i'm not fighting a young man like
that who we're a little infamous but
originally it was only supposed to be
big george and then tall george goes
that sounds like something i wanted i
love that he's doing that yeah so i hit
up our boy rich chow who put it all
together i'm like hey we got another guy
wants to do it he's like say last pretty
cool dead orientation yesterday uh i'm
sorry on saturday tall george said he
spent the entire hour under mount of a
giant black guy
well there's like i was like how was it
he's like is it
some giant black girl's not telling me
learning you got to learn how to get
there are men that can impose their will
on you learning how to get up george
apparently thought it was just going to
be an orientation he was like i thought
we're going to go up he's going to show
us around the
uh gym and stuff
they got right to work good yeah right
no that's that's what happens yeah
all right today we're just going to look
at our binders i've been sending them
bro look at the footballs i've been
sending brandon a lot of video on on uh
pierre learning how to wrestle dude oh
yeah you sent me you want to change your
tone bro no i what did i tell you you
sent me that video i went here i sent a
video of pierre doing like basic
bluebell [ __ ] he was shrimping out he
was getting his hips out like the basics
basically what tall george is doing okay
yeah like super basic and it doesn't
look proficient at it or but like
do you want to change your battery oh
yeah i want to increase it you want to
do 10 grand after seeing this yeah
pierre is learning how to [ __ ]
wrestle dude
well when i think about that i go let me
see somebody's takedown like how you
know
that's for me at least you know
coming from a very high level wrestling
background um looking at how somebody
actually you know that's at least
something i can measure well i would say
he has to learn how to not get taken
down or at least get back on his feet
that would be what i would work with
yeah for sure so i've never seen izzy
attempt a takedown correct yeah i don't
know what that
and he is
you know
izzy's got to go down a pound for pound
one of the best top five is he there yet
no he's not
one of the best middleweights ever for
that's right but pound for pound yeah
yeah who do you got
let me guess jones not even close jones
100 jones on one mighty mouse take jones
out of my mouse right
my mouse top five he's not my number one
no i'm saying tough too light of
awakening
let me guess could be
yeah never lost i only last one round
most dominant champion we've ever had
khabib number one gsp
he won every time
for a long time well not every time and
jose aldo's got to be in there for what
nine years
would you say yeah i mean volcanowski
you could argue he's crazy after a
competition and at a higher level right
now
um i don't know if he has tougher
competition i mean when
the sport's so new every year the
competition started
yeah
so you know stuff that they're also
pound for pounds so subjective it's just
whatever whoever but there's no
i don't think there's any disagreement
when it comes to john jones you could
say
opd's whatever like that all right
doesn't matter
when everybody where a lot of people
were doing pdes the guys were he was
beating the [ __ ] up we're on more pd's
correct and he spot vitor belfort he
fought [ __ ] little cheetah
you know i can keep listing guys you
want to edit that out no what do you
mean no they all test it hot oh okay
well this is just common knowledge so
i'm not earning anybody's laundry out
you throw balfour and leon
ohio yeah
a lot of people test it out
um yeah he's my number one maybe you
should get extra credit for beating guys
who test hot you know that's what i
think it's more the level of difficulty
was so much harder back then because
those guys weren't some real [ __ ] yeah
you're gonna if you're gonna take away
people's credit for being on steroids
like well he beat up the [ __ ] sauced
up vitor well that's a primer jones
beats handedly beat daniel cormier and
took him down you don't would be taking
daniel cormier took down with a double
leg okay daniel cormier no two-time
olympian nobody takes daniel cormier
down like that's incredible that john
jones is nuts it's insane he out
wrestled him took him down
and put him on his back like what are
you talking about then gus finn did it
to john
did gusman take johnny come down and i
called it because i was training with
gus finn and i didn't realize how good
his wrestling was and i was like oh i
guarantee you guys can get john down
because trevor both of them said i
guarantee you sure enough you got him
down really yeah
[ __ ] guessing's chain wrestling was
filthy filthy filthy yeah
um
all right what do you got is he is
gustafson retired or heavyweight i think
no he's back at light heavy right now
okay uh krylov right indicator anything
to
jon jones uh is he when is he fighting
we don't know john no he's fighting
stipe this year okay
yeah
you don't know which one i want
man cracks penis during sex
happened to my buddy i sent him this
article so i said do you guys think to
my buddy first yeah and i sent to you
guys diagnosed with rare eggplant
deformity i'm telling you my buddies
look like a big old purple eggplant it's
internal bleeding that's all it is
you're not filling up with blood oh my
god where is his dick i can't tell
really oh no on the left it looks like
that's
this right but is that after surgery or
i think that's before this is the weird
one this looks like it's going all the
way back up yeah that's snail that's the
snail on the right there that's the
snail well escargot on the right so 50
year old patient also 50. so that dick's
not a spring chicken
a 50 year old patient had reported to
the hospital that his penis had been
swollen for hours following this mishap
in the sack
i told you my buddy hooking up with a
real wildcat
he's a big boy she wanted as hard as
possible see he [ __ ] had hike rudy
style going for that sack yeah and he
just missed went right and butt cheek to
that's gotta [ __ ] be a problem
snapped it dude ah
dude
jesus christ i think in the hospital i
thought we were a gay couple
well think that happened to dennis robin
once he tells the story about like
diving into this girl's vagina
uh because he asked her to or she asked
him to and you know snaps did you see
that if you miss
and he has a baby pipe
did you see that [ __ ] uh
there's this thing going around on
wherever was real instagram where guy
goes well guys i'm getting divorced
uh that's it he's like there's a picture
of his car he's getting in he's like i'm
[ __ ] getting divorced my wife doesn't
love me anymore and so you just see his
wife go what the [ __ ] are you talking
about and he goes
you won't get you you don't love me so i
guess we're getting divorced that's the
end of that she goes what are you saying
cause well what did you just say to me
and she goes
i said i'm not going to let you put your
dick in my butt and then put it in my
mouth and he goes same thing
same thing
i was like oh my god
that batman sketch pete holmes did
and he's like he's like in a in a was it
in an order that be surprised ask that
your mouth
that's not bad i just saw pete holmes uh
at a barbecue he's so great he's funny
he's so funny he's funny pete's now
lifting weights and he's like dude i
like this feeling i'm lifting i go start
eating meat you'll be even more manly
yeah because he he's vegan right yeah he
goes but i started lifting weights and i
started getting more irritable my like
testosterone he goes i love it i go yeah
dude
be as big as you can be he's enormous by
the way he's a big dude
he's a weird body he has like that like
lunch lady like hips well yeah he has
like wide hips yeah he likes to eat his
uh so funny though oh he's a great pete
is so funny so he's such a good actor
too he's showing uh i love it i think i
think that with lady some yeah he's
great shawn hbo yeah he's just great i
love the guy he's just a great guy
was it crashing crashing yeah yes great
[ __ ] show one of my favorite shows
ever
how many followers is he a big 269 okay
he's just great he's funny his wife's
great he's got this beautiful little
girl he's super talented looking great
what else you got too
this here mark there we go
whoa
wow
crab whiskey huh huh uh-huh
yeah but new hampshire distillery is
taking on the problem of
green crabs that are invasive pests
plaguing north america's marine
ecosystem for more than 200 years so
they're solving that problem
by making green crab flavored whiskey i
wonder how they're distilling it with
the crab because
there has to be some health issues there
because how are
they they're killing the crabs and i'm
sure
they're distilling the whiskey with the
crabs inside of it
people are going to hear crab whiskey
and i'd venture to say three quarters of
them are going to go no absolutely not
they distill it using a vacuum
a glass string that allows for precise
temperature control
weird if you can get them to taste it
they totally change their tune for the
most part
maybe we should order a little bit yeah
i'll be down yeah
can you order it or no
scroll down to it i guess it makes it
yeah
oh it's time
so do you do they
do they ferment the crabs and then just
distill it
and it's out of new hampshire so it's
going to be
oh wait
yeah it's new hampshire
whiskey
all right
so i guess they eat about 40 muscles a
day per crab oh wow
problem yeah what any muscles i don't
believe that one crab no
is that what it says believe it yeah
yeah you can go back it's 40 muscles and
then go to shopping
um i don't see it on there
see a daddy rack whiskey which looked
cool iraq
apparently can't buy this right now at
least not right now
we'll find it later it can't be too good
and you want to do this one again mark
yes so i thought this is interesting um
and i saw somebody messaged you about uh
it in on ig so message me
yeah they were like please bring
attention to this
and this court ruling may take 70 000
truckers off-road spur jams
to shoot into
okay oh hold on
yes i guess the the the rule is
um
you can't be a self-employed trucker
anymore holy [ __ ] that's what my grandpa
and uncle did why yeah owner operators
in california have a week to seize
businesses this is the plan for the why
fuel prices
i don't understand because supply and
demand
um it was a lot well it's going to have
an effect on that but i guess the the
association asked the supreme court for
review of a case challenging
california's assembly bill five a law
that sets out three tests to determine
whether or not an employee entitled to
job benefits or an independent
contractor who isn't the trucking
industry relies on contractors and is
fought to be exempt from state
regulations for years
because of federal laws with few
exceptions the relationship between
independent truckers and their carriers
brokers and shippers have never been
governed by the tests i have no idea i'm
already so bored i'm sorry i've never
been more bored in my life we said this
can be the best podcast ever that
picture and that that everything about
that is boring me too is the truck on
fire like if it was on fire i mean that
picture
[ __ ] blurry picture we can't read the
article it may take a decision to add
fuel to ongoing i'm already like out i'm
already out move on to this then all the
energy left my body
ah yes another bite this guy
so and sucks there's like parts of this
video that you'll you'll notice there's
a really dick move on one of the guys
but i don't know if he's the grandfather
or the father but check this out it's
different from the one we've already
watched this is different this new one
this is a yellowstone
oh you're sammy i mean i think
i know we saw this one because i see the
kid right did we see the mom
the guy runs away from the kid and this
guy grabbed oh wow he ditches the
[ __ ] kid well you got to get the kid
away from there who's the dumbass in the
hat that's what i'm saying i don't know
if it's a grandfather
you bring a child near that that that
buffalo there's i think the bison is
attacking because they're terrible hats
but why would you bring people that
close to you i know that's the problem
have you ever seen a bison person
they're [ __ ] huge dude of course yeah
and the orange shirt
[Music]
he just realized it's behind him he bear
sprayed him or sprayed him with
something
you have that kid in here how about your
grandpa just goes [ __ ] the kid yeah so
this guy saved the kids i really grandpa
ditched the kid [ __ ] shout out to
there's guys saving the kids yeah i
think i start all in the same family so
i don't know what yeah get the kid out
of there because i got gourd he got
gourd under his arm good though but also
he just felt
a family of idiots dude this is also god
being like i gotta get rid of some
people
but it could teach you don't have a
child near a [ __ ] wild
not just that you guys don't go near
them of course everybody don't go in
there of course and there are signs
everywhere yeah it's yellowstone yeah i
know there are a lot of people that were
putting their [ __ ] toddlers on top of
a [ __ ] boat uh bison think about this
and guess what they shouldn't have kids
they got killed they shouldn't have kids
um let's see oh you know that rumor
that's been going on forever that derek
jeter gives hell girls you know yeah
signed eight by ten so there's going to
be a i think a seven part something
studies on espn a documentary i'm in
about him and his [ __ ] about him and
his life oh and then he just oh
he's saying that that's not i was like
he also played basketball baseball yeah
he's one of the greats espn got rid of
the whole woke agenda huh it's about
time to make something good
yeah but they're like no no this is a
shunning derek jeter for being a real
animal in the sack but i guess he goes
on to say that that never happened just
it's just that story just kind of blew
up and kept growing sounds like it's a
good story like sounds like it's true
and he's defending himself oh that's it
yeah nothing wrong with it giving people
a gift basket
and did you see this so my buddy my
buddy said this called this a long time
ago he was like uh
he doesn't have the money it doesn't
make sense no he does have the money bad
he has the money he has the money he is
the money b he actually didn't no he has
the money the problem is is he uh
the problem is go ahead chin yeah so
he's saying that
that twitter's not revealing exactly how
many people or how many people that are
using the program are actually bots not
people but if how many are bots and like
spam they're saying it's not like less
than five percent and he's like i need
to see it okay so here because they make
money off of real users so if you're
going to blow it up to work like you
know yeah the evaluation before that
even came out
the people that i know who you know make
a lot of money and know this they went
it's not going to happen i said what do
you mean he goes
so when you say he's got 41 billion
dollars or well he has more than that
whatever yeah yeah the deal is 44.
that's
that number has to be put into context
which is that stock
now if elon musk were to liquidate a
stock and buy
you know first of all you have to get
somebody to buy all that stock second of
all once he did that once he sold that
stock that much of the company
it would tank
so much you can't do that you can't you
know even if you sold a billion dollars
worth of stock it it it throws a lot of
[ __ ] because what happens is the market
goes wait a minute why are you selling
this do you not have faith in your
company it's already lost 40 of its
value i don't know if you know that but
it's lost 40 of its value already mm-hmm
and that's that's a recent number too
that since when it was it's high it's
lost 40 percent
so
there are a lot of factors here
so when people say well he's the richest
man in the world yes on paper but
these stocks
you're tied to that number and you're
tied to your stock you can't go selling
your stock you can't liquidate your
stock without getting a major without
collapsing the company sometimes if you
sell enough of it but how much does it
say he's worth 10
because i know that 44 million is not
that much a lot of that a lot of that is
a lot of that is all you know also it's
a bad buy how would you make your money
back there's a whole bunch of things
yeah but that's where the company's
worth
it's what it's worth right now with
stock yeah so if you're worth 237
billion 44 billion eight [ __ ]
it is doesn't change he doesn't have
access to 44 billion he does not have
access i don't know if he doesn't have
access to it no dude he doesn't let me
tell you why
because you'd have to sell your stock it
doesn't mean you have to sell your stock
doesn't mean you have to sell your stock
in just tesla here's so much other stuff
that's tesla stock for the most part
that's his wealth is tied up with that
that company he was no he was rich
before tesla not like that though not
240 billion she's a billionaire before
tesla you start tesla office money you
cannot it's it doesn't mean there's a
lot of cash in the bank it means you
have a shitload of money in stock that's
all about 70 of tesla yeah
45 stocks company spacex
yeah and most of his money's uh yeah
spacex is a big boy yeah
so much of this is
i bet he could come with a 44 billion no
i feel like it could too yeah i don't
know
i bet he could not
but he said he but he's saying yeah they
weren't up front with everything and
then also but now twitter the people are
sounding like nah but you can't back out
yeah but it was like but you already
broke the negotiating deal yeah he'll
say his out is
this company is not who you presented to
yeah which is fair yes it is but this is
what he posted as well this meme which
is
hilarious i think and they wouldn't
disclose bot info
now they want to force me to buy twitter
in court now they have to scroll up i
don't know how you don't like him
he's a guy's guy i don't get how you
don't [ __ ] with nothing
he's the best and he's also incredibly
innovative and you need him
i love when they like talk about them
about that asshole's like [ __ ] elon musk
hey you stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] some
congress person in california
he pays more in taxes than you will ever
know you can't even say the number you
[ __ ] yeah he also drove his business
where you [ __ ] more you know how much
he pays in taxes how much you benefited
no he posted it like i forget him seven
billion like seven billion
what else you guys do shut up this right
here i saw this post by tim kennedy yeah
and i'll just show you his post which i
think is great
that's the picture of brittany griner
and this is what he said
time you were protesting even requesting
that the national anthem not be played
at your games then going back to the
same government and pleading that they
intervene on your behalf to get you out
of a russian prison after you illegally
brought drugs into their country
does not get more ironic than this even
with her despicable behavior i do
believe that every american is worth
fighting for even those that hate their
own country he's hilarious [ __ ] he's
the best tim captain america kennedy i
love him so she uh pleaded with guilty
to it but they're saying that's just a
ploy to get her it's gonna make it
easier for negotiation yeah because
russia's just holding on to her because
they want to exchange for her and
there's something about i would say this
just shows you how much america cares
about the wnba that was steph curry he'd
be in there for two hours
wnb they're like yeah it's really tough
to negotiate what is going to happen do
you think with her do we know should get
out in a few months we'll send them you
know well she's got to plead guilty sure
he did
um
yeah
wow yeah
yeah i wouldn't be bringing drugs into
[ __ ] yeah but she was i did it for
years no she did it forever because she
was with the oligarchs yeah because the
oligarchs on the team they're like
you're fine they're not going to check
you if they do come call me and then she
got caught she's like call whatever
vadim and like oh vadim is on the run on
a yacht right now so he's not answering
so we don't know who the [ __ ] you're
talking about well abroad
abramovic
i think he owns chelsea or man united
abramovic is the russian oligarch who's
met he's so [ __ ] i think they seized
all his assets can you look up
brahma he seized his boat
yeah yeah they found him he would always
be at fabricio's uh
restaurant in saint parts he would
always come in and you know and
right now roman abramovich yeah not
anymore
hired lawyers
oh let's see sanctioned russian
billionaire hired lawyers costing up to
1500 an hour days after our u.s warrant
seized his private jets they're coming
after him all the way holy [ __ ]
and that's the thing because these
oligarchs are looking up like hey dude
be cool man [ __ ] with all our
stuff no that that's what they're doing
yes that's well that's america knows
that it's like oh all your boys check
this out that giant yacht you don't want
you're seeing putin's yet
punjab's nazos
yeah he's got ties for sure to putin
oh yeah yeah
so you make it rough on your boys though
well you know my buddy said that he
knows people that [ __ ] did business
with abramovic and abramovitz would just
violate the contract and then you the
people that would [ __ ] try to sue him
would just disappear
because they had russian
people close to putin that would just be
like no you're we're making money off
this the kremlin's making money off this
and they would just play ball or [ __ ]
die or disappear in in especially if
they're a russian businessman in
london or whatever they would just die
they just disappear so nobody want to do
business with them my buddy
was going to do business and was like
his his friend said you can't do who
doesn't see that guy [ __ ] that
she'll violate everything the same buddy
you don't think elon has a billion
dollars just wanna know who we're
talking about uh that's two of them i
know two people that yeah
no he has a lot of money they love elon
musk they love him it doesn't sound like
it they love it sounds like he's kind of
[ __ ] sounds like some shade 41 billion
dollars bubba that's
but when you're worth 240 billion it's
that number is very that number can
change overnight
um i want to just play this video for
you and just let me know what you think
is going on with this woman she's a news
anchor right here is so amazing oh she's
hammered
meteorologist craig
of course clearly like here we're taking
a live look over uh downtown albany and
and of course just like me meteorologist
craig gold is working a double shift and
so um he's in and we've been we've been
tracking this and you know we've been
human like what it's been like across
the country and the different reasons
that why it's so hot in other areas and
we're having really nice weather here so
let's get over to craig
i think it's uh prescriptions
it does feel like it's prescriptions too
but she was saying it's because she's
working double shifts and she was
exhausted i bet she took some [ __ ] she
might have taken something that [ __ ]
with her head totally on friday i was
not the poor lady dude on friday
notified the station i would not be
renewing my contract expires july 31st
saturday i was scheduled to work early
morning six game shift and the evening
shift i was sleep deprived and exhausted
and so moving on tonight is we have to
tell you also you know like the other
news happening there and i feel bad for
her give her a break man yeah i feel bad
for her too you gotta be a little
professional her face looks super
crooked though i have to like it just so
there's pictures of her i love her
i love how she's just rambling she's
like you know she's
she might have been so exhausted and at
the same time you don't talk about stuff
i think exhausting
medication or was like
maybe in between should i have a few
drinks that's right
probably
and she's like all right guys is that
hot out there yeah
she's [ __ ] hot
you want to do this one
yeah
okay so an anti-abortion activist
did it
did it help the cause yep so this guy's
pro lifer well yeah he's actually the
reason that roe versus wade was
overturned
yeah cause he climbed the building
oh boy
i saw some videos of people on the
inside of the hotel you're like oh there
he comes and he's coming up here and i
mean god it's it's not it's crazy
scaling the new york times building yeah
new york oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
wow that's ballsy as [ __ ] the video was
awful oh i don't see them the videos are
tough today fellas
i don't even see a video starting
sometimes it's a monday you know what we
did we set ourselves up because you said
best show ever and it's been the worst i
think this is the greatest year we've
ever done uh maison de calm tower san
francisco
so house of
champs the house of champs he calls
himself
pro-life spider-man his name is
salesforce tower in san francisco
wow can we see him that's it
for him he's just like god
i need to climb for a reason what's
happening
that's a very high building
oh it's insane dude
yeah holy this video sucks ass too i
can't see anything else i see nobody
right
right there right here it looks like
you're hanging off a balcony
holy crap
go climb a mountain bro
go climb a mountain and have him do a
dog
oh he's trying to make it all exciting
hear about the mountain climber who put
his hand he was climbing and he put his
hand up he was on a rattlesnake and he
got bit and he just went
and just it's on video
really
40 minutes
we're like this [ __ ] is this
what else you got you want some more
just uh and not a good one for me
that's a good one please have a good one
i beg you too
you want the olympic one what is it
we can look at uh a former olympian was
attacked in la by a homeless dude
through a pipetter we could talk about
how that's fine i don't wanna see you uh
that's fun
amber heard uh says 10 million is unfair
but in reality johnny depp should have
got like 40 million
for being real apparently uh he has a
new movie coming out
[ __ ] up yeah i don't like this oh is
it but is this in pasadena
downtown earlier i think right yeah
which is where homeless people do attack
people let me see yeah
oh you're watching eating a lot by
sharks
who survived you can't watch all right
oh my gosh video because she's
attractive too a lot of messages coming
in and i don't want to have to repeat
myself and i appreciate all the love um
and i'm sure it's just going to get out
and around so
i might as well pedro munoz did the same
video no what happened um uh yesterday i
was in downtown l.a and i had a lunch
she's pretty as i was sleeping you see a
picture related to inside and i was
saying goodbye to a friend
and um
this homeless man ran up
um he had something in his hand on he
was other side of the car
in the street
and he just like looked at me with some
pretty
hateful eyes
and um as i turned to go tell my friend
i think something's like wrong with him
and i think he's going to hit a car
before i knew it a big
metal bolt
like pipe
hit me and
hit me
didn't affect that flawless skin god
damn is that a horde filter that skin is
flawless [ __ ] up jesus she's pretty
there she is
[Music]
but also it's good for her
good for her good for her
i mean that homeless guy probably did it
right because she's attracted to females
crazy people there's no video of her
getting hit huh go downtown be aware
oh yeah i have your head on a swivel
down your head on a swivel
oh yeah i had there oh wait you had that
ready u.s women's national team play for
years six foot three university of
arizona
also modeled in her time off yeah
appeared in 2011 sports illustrated
swimsuit model that [ __ ] homeless cat
of all the people dude
don't hit the pretty ones you know
have some decency this is the last one
this is in please tell me this is people
getting bombarded by a tsunami by sea
lions and this is about
in san diego
yeah they're a little uh i know exactly
where that is too i know exactly
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
where they just came out of nowhere
started [ __ ] chasing people
territorial they're like get the [ __ ]
out of here yeah
this is our area domination they don't
stop they keep going
do you wanna hear the crazy things
that's happened in san diego like insane
dude it's gonna blow your mind insane
i'm there next week thursday friday
saturday
what factory san diego heart of san
diego last week yeah what next week the
beach isn't safe it's probably best to
just go to the comedy you know what yeah
you get off the beaches go to the laugh
act in the heart of san diego july 21st
to the 23rd but this week i'm in fort
wayne indiana that's easy to get to b
so please come out fort wayne i'll never
be back
i just want to be dead honest
it's a summer play
and you know summer's tough so i said
you want fort wayne let's do it it's
gonna be fun
fort wayne let's come on out july 14th
through the 16th then shobhan friends is
next wednesday guys who own it ha run
some great they do they've never steered
me wrong they're some of my favorite in
the business
uh then shop and friends
it's at the improv next wednesday july
20th late show 8pm so it's going to be a
little cooler for us i'm sick of
performing during the daylight san diego
is next week as well july 21st to 23rd
then baltimore chicago is august 26th
it's at the den theater it's one night
only friday night in the heart of uh
chicago downtown chicago not schomburg
like i've been doing it's in the heart
of chicago den theater is the 26th one
show only so that bad [ __ ] will sell
out but we're there because the 27th is
the tough mudder outside of chicago the
thick mudder you use the promo code team
brendan because it's team brendan the
thick boys versus the buttery bros in
chicago tough mudder sign up for the 10
a.m race all right get you some that's
appleton houston boston but fort wayne
you're up this week let's go san diego
next uh check out best of with brian
kellen on youtube uh dropping this tammy
the bull this week uh we got five
episodes going strong check that out i
will be at the milwaukee improv brand in
july 21 22-23
july 21 warm it up for me i'm there
november night might be working with
working out with the marquette
basketball team might do something there
we'll see what happens i got to come up
with some ideas for my best stuff play
basketball well we'll see oh dude have
to uh go in the locker room
no do the biggest dick contest i could
do the biggest dick pockets go in the
locker room and go maybe i'll do that
too maybe i'll do a camera shawl fog you
see these big long pipes just big old
pipes everywhere and then you measure
the best stuff and just call it and call
that episode pipes best best of pipes
best stick and i know steamy pipes let's
find the biggest stick steamy pipes
featuring marquette's basketball steamy
pipes
steamy pipes is great i'm just
spitballing ideas i love it it sounds
like a great tv show austin texas cap
city july 28th 29th it's gonna be fun i
might have a special guest show up you
know oh i wish i was in town certain
comic that lives in austin might be
making a surprise appearance you might
want to get your tickets at cap city
another hint he's not vaccinated he he
may or may not be vaccinated but he's a
thick guy another hint has the same
haircut as jada pig and smith
that's good
nashville tennessee zanies oh that's a
fun one
then i got spokane washington spokane
spokane favorite club comedy club
september 22 2013. you got some good
dates on there daddy i can't wait
uh wait what is it raining here nope
oh terrible teardrop city
wow sorry impressive thanks dude i love
it daddy's getting tanned love you guys